what's up guys this is tracks
quarantined here in the diamond district
and today we're gonna review some rapper
chains and pendants plant baseball a
chain my people tracks every single
diamond different cuts you know we had
to make something uncopyable so my boy
Jody high rollers neon Dale dad Tony
riffraff whatever he's going by today he
likes to switch up his names all the
time he wanted me to make him a chain I
wanted to make him something that's
gonna pop out that's gonna set the
standard that these other guys gonna
have to keep up with the one thing we
did and the eye-catching piece is the
glasses are made out of a pink sapphire
hand cut I have to cut several different
sand fires before I got the perfect fit
for my boy behind the eyes the diamond
shine right through the sapphires all
right hand pave on the full piece so
that was all hand done the other tricky
thing about this piece is that the piece
is actually the lock that's right the
chains lock into the piece so you could
switch up the heads at any point of time
if you want to make a new wolf head or
whatever pops into his head at any point
of time we're gonna make something
unique and crazy and we'll be able to
plug it right in and then we have
something going on another level we did
a specialized nugget Miami Cuban All
American classic with the Cuban link
mixed in with different cuts of diamonds
round cuts but get cuts princess cuts
you name it we put it into the chain
unique white gold and rose gold and
because I had to hook up my boy I
stuffed it with over a kilos worth of
gold
blackboard JB so black boy has his piece
done by Eliana he's got the bandana made
out of enamel and it's a grape the grape
is having it looks like a time on a
great time fully iced around his neck
nice and three-dimensional what is the
significance of the grape and the
bandana you're gonna have to ask black
boy I wouldn't be able to tell you
myself but that Miami Cuban change
seamlessly going through the hidden bail
is what really sets the piece off it
keeps it up high it's not a dangling low
that's the newer look that's the look
that I personally recommend that's
what's up rowdy rich so rowdy rich did
not cut corners with his jewelry he
spent a big boy dollars and I'll tell
you why because he's got the custom
chain to go with the custom pendant if
you really want to stand out with
amongst the other competition of
everybody buying jewelry and getting
these monster size 100 300 thousand
dollar ice out pieces you gotta have a
custom chain he's got a custom barbed
wire chain to go with this barbed wire
piece big heavy carats big heavy gold
alright he's got some blue going on over
there and then when he's popping out at
the basketball game he took it to
another level
he's got three tennis chains off that
longest tennis chain he's got this blue
enameled piece with the electric enamel
in the background that piece has got the
highest quality diamonds out of the
whole set the barbed wire custom Cuban
is something I've never seen before it's
sick it's beautiful
he's got a very hidden bail on there so
you can't even see how that even works
the combination is another elite rapper
set alright we're talking about 300 to
500 thousand dollars on a setup like
this
yo gotti yo gotti has the beautiful
Rockefeller Kane was likely a gift from
the label it's a classic piece timeless
piece was made popular by jay-z but he's
got it hanging on some big boy pointer
tennis chains alright big stones two of
them are matching okay which is the most
beautiful look and then he's got a
little smaller one on a little shorter
and at the top I fully iced Miami Cuban
chain and what are the prices all right
on the Rockefeller chain you could say
ten thousand not the craziest price
range it's a beautiful piece however the
big boy pointer chains are 30,000 30,000
and the other one is around 20,000 with
the Miami Cuban chain at least $20,000
on that as well so another big boy set
Travis Scott so Travis Scott is another
hip-hop Elite artist I spent close to a
million dollars on jewelry alright again
he's not holding back
you've got the flame chain with the
flame of Miami Cuban all flame all fire
all fully ice on the side inside
everything burning up with crazy amounts
of diamonds and you know the best part
of it when you're in the elites right
you want to have that custom link
negotiate with your jeweler make sure
that he comes through with something
that flows and sits and this one was not
cut any corners
alright the flaming Cuban that's a
unique look only he's got it he's on
fire with that piece black youngster
black youngster is always flashing money
he's always flashing big pieces he is
not cutting back on spending on jewelry
so he got about like kilos worth of gold
on and about 200 to 300 carats of
diamonds right not playing around big
stacks big racks all to the jeweler and
he's walking out super Iced Out West
Side gun so West Side guns got a
ridiculous collection of jewelry around
his neck from different periods of his
life and with different significance as
different meanings he's got his loved
ones made into jewelry with the picture
pendant and the pendant under
one is fully ice and one is with the
picture printed on to gold all right
with a clear coat of enamel over it
that's a very classic piece you could
put it up on a shelf and it's still like
a beautiful golden diamond picture
portrait that the whole family can enjoy
right rope chains in there was mixed
with big boy Miami Cubans fully ice
locks a lot going on on his neck and at
the bottom he's got a ridiculous long
safe piece with another individual on it
he's not following the trends he's doing
his own thing on everything he had yfn
lucci wife Anne Lucci is not playing
around he's another big boy that spent
350 to 450 thousand dollars with his
jeweler on custom jewelry he's got a
custom Miami Cuban on there around cut
diamonds all around with a upper level
one room never seen that before so he
might have had that custom-made because
when you want your pieces you want
something that no one else has end of
story
the other big boy Cuban that he's got is
really really nice
upper level flat laying very very elite
three row Cuban okay so that's extra
gold slapped on to a Cuban with a
beautiful layering of diamonds all right
he's not stopping there okay he's got
big boy tennis chain pointers and
hanging off of all that he's got the 650
with the baguettes now those aren't full
cut baguettes but they flow very nice
into that 650 it's a white gold rose
gold mix here that's what he's going for
all pave diamonds on the side again big
boy numbers here he threw the money down
he wants to compete on the elite rapper
scale and he's doing it with this setup
right here young ma so young and may
wanted to do a unique piece she had this
card piece that she wanted to make with
the Queen instead of the Q she wanted
the K that's kind of her logo kind of
her style I wanted to put the different
color white and red and black enamel in
it to make it look like a card she
thought that would be cartoony i
overrode that decision because enamel is
removable I put it in there any
I showed it to her just like I thought
she loved it she couldn't even imagine
that it could look like that I have a
jeweler's imagination she's obviously an
artist we had to combine a little bit
and make it work beautiful enamel
beautiful detail it's a slick card piece
and she loves it she wears it in layers
with her other jewelry we got the Cuban
change for her as well rose gold and
white gold sometimes she switches up the
colors she comes back here gets it in
yellow gold and rose gold she wants to
dip something from white gold rose gold
we do it all I use the best diamonds in
the diamond district for it I did not
cut any corners because Buhler is not
supposed to be money thrown away Juli
supposed to be something that you can
pass down through generations that
people who are reluctant to sell and
want to keep and that's what we did with
this piece money bag yo money bag yo did
not cut any quarters on this piece he's
got a monster set up over here all right
based on those baguettes diamonds in the
dollar sign I know it came from Philly I
know the jewelers that are making it
down there they got a beautiful parcel
baguettes I'm not gonna hate on it
they're putting it into these pieces and
they're setting up these pieces real
real night but there's nothing that any
jeweler can do unless they have the
budget and money bag yells definitely
dropped a monster-sized money bag on
this piece the chain that's on it is
actually also very impressive the way it
links in the way is set up the way it
flows with that money bag and got unique
letters and initials on it actually
harder to make that chain than it is
that piece but those baguettes are not
slacking either the money bag is stuffed
up lots of gold all white gold
we've got rose gold mixed in there as
well of course on the dollar sign the
ticket well listen I mean it's getting
close
at least a quarter of a million to four
to $50,000 on a piece like this ty dolla
sign so ty dolla sign is doing something
different all right at first glance it
looks like the average set up but it's
not he's got this beautiful Mariner cut
or sometimes it's called the tiger's eye
link all right it's a link that's used
for anchors that are going to the bottom
of the ocean but he's got it around his
neck fully iced I've never seen that
before that's a tough chain of fully ice
he's got a cross on that with a symbol
in the center of it and other crosses
hanging off that change very very
designer very very unique not a lot of
people having something like that the
classic Cuban chain is there that's a
heavy choker Cuban at the top fully iced
white gold with a one-eyed pig pendant
hanging off the tennis chain I don't
know what the significance of it is but
I like it
little mosey little mosey got some flour
type chain going on and white gold never
seen it before these again unique
designer pieces that people pick up when
they're not trying to look like every
other rapper goes well with the rest of
his outfit and all of his uniqueness
that he's got going on
rose gold Cubans hanging off with a
thunderbolt pendant at the top that
cloud hitmaker all right beautiful rose
gold it's it's a nice subtle look it's
not as crazy but it's unique that's
what's important out here
it's not all about throwing away a
million dollars on jewelry it's about
getting that unique look that makes you
look like how you feel
and I think he's making it happen in
this setup kidding
kid ink is going gold heavy on this
piece diamonds are for shine and gold is
for investment he's got a mix of both
here his money safe and secure he's not
throwing it in the air got a classic
gold Cuban with a diamond lock Gold
heavy piece with a bulldog on the front
right with that gold finish around it I
love it personally if you want to burn
through money you get fully fully iess
than you spend a quarter million half a
million but your gold is gonna be safer
in the long run that's just the way the
jewelry game works very good look his
money safe he's gonna be doing great
with that one in the long term so the
jewelry game is a very competitive game
and there's a lot going on it's a lot
changing the biggest thing on the block
right now is the custom change built in
with the custom pendant it's got to be a
matching set and it's all got to be
custom made the classic fully iced Cuban
even though it's forty thousand fifty
thousand dollars is not good enough you
got to spend more and you got to have
your jeweler make a custom link now he
can't slack on that link that's the
tough part right we're pushing the
envelope with that custom link and the
way it blends in we're dependent just a
bail no good slinging through not enough
it's got a link with the piece it's got
to be one solid set that Wow's people
when they see it otherwise you're
slacking